[Music]  this little old lady is button a 21 year  old margay  her name comes from the phrase cute as a  button  [Music]  the margae is a tree-dwelling cat native  to the dense forests in central and  south america  these expert climbers will hunt sleep  and even give birth in the trees  the margae's wide feet and flexible toes  allow them to climb jump and hang from  tree limbs  their long heavy tails keep the animal  balanced and their large eyes make them  excellent night hunters preying on birds  reptiles and even small primates  mages will hardly ever cross open  treeless areas making them extremely  sensitive to deforestation  in addition the illegal fur and pet  trades have made this wildcat and  near-threatened species  the best hope for the margay's continued  survival is to preserve their natural  forest habitat this is the margae  [Music]  you